today's topic infidelity also in the
black community I wanna you know I don't
speak for the black community but I do
think that a lot of black men they
really don't know how to have true
faithful relationships they think
because they have money because they
have power that they can treat women any
kind of way Loni love is saying and that
is something we need to work on we need
to work on it empower does not mean that
you can just do it here's something
that's really messed up what I was
researching this and you guys may not
even like this part of the conversation
wow oh wow
so he's interesting rich people cheat
more poor people cheat less okay like we
would predominately come from lower
socioeconomic backgrounds yes I thought
it was interesting that despite that we
still yeah but here's the other thing
that's messed up okay so I had read this
study a long time ago that said that
people with elevated levels of
testosterone are more likely to be
single more likely to cheat more likely
to be in non-monogamous relationships
okay and so that I looked it up and then
college students black and white were
compared black students had 20% more
testosterone so I'm like oh my god is
this [ __ ] biological and then they did a
study brother I
it blew my mind I don't know oh yeah
yeah cuz people like know what you did
like it's not me it's biology
daddy's gonna do some it was Anita's
biology keeping it on the sofa biology
we even did it in the bathroom
biology I told you they're not ready
do you wanna know it's biology keep it
on low
cuz I can't keep can't see anymore
remakes biology biology so lockrey yeah
I'll just throw the biology saga biology
oh wow Rob this study messed me up
because I was coming into this video
like what am I gonna say this stuff but
even but it is what I found and they
then they did a cross study with people
in Africa and doing this found the same
thing people with higher levels of
testosterone were more likely even in
Africa so it wasn't just a matter of
cultural where you are it was done
across so that became super suit to me I
know you know with testosterone there's
still hypothesizing why those people are
more prone you can excuse to a whole
bunch of people I know but let's also
not kid ourselves our biology is not
necessarily an excuse to just
automatically do whatever you want yeah
really it does influence it does raise
the likelihood what it doesn't mean it's
the only factor that determines what
kind of behavior you're gonna engage it
and so I'm just laying down all the
information of what I found I didn't
want to hide anything from you guys
whether I wanted to or not so many
cultures that is a small thing that goes
across the board but I'm gonna say it's
not across the board because what is
happening is and because our families
were broken up
we still do not have idea of how to have
together the families because our family
she's basing yourself on which she lived
so sorry for me to go against what she
lived I'm not saying that that's the
case but that's what she lived and
that's one thing now what you lived is
not necessarily an indication of what
the reality of what it is it's ur
perception
I believe it's across the board and
listen and she's more thing for again
the money
you get the power you get the respect
people abuse of that you men that are in
position of power abuse of that I don't
think it's a black thing it's a thing
so you're saying people's money in power
cheap more no I think manche woman cheap
it's not just men not black men not
black woman it's people cheap I've seen
it left I see that right so you don't
think it has an influence it might be
what do you think about that well the
facts are pretty clear people with more
money cheat away more men are with man
or woman men more men more than women
there's more money cheat more than women
with more money you're talking about
this generally speaking yeah at a
younger age cheat more than men you know
once you get older it's mainly cheat
more often obviously it's not surprising
for women cheat more on younger and in
yeah that's you yeah so because
obviously they're in their prime years
and so in their younger years it's a lot
more accessible it's a lot easier with
less risk as you get older you want to
settle down the prospect of a family
becomes dimmer you don't have as many
suitors as you do and you don't see the
opposite way exactly as men get into
their prime they have more options they
do whatever they want here's the
infidelity is different for men and
women for men infidelity is a matter of
options generally speaking as men have
more options their likelihood to cheat
raises dramatically and so that's why
you see what successful men men with
money power influence infidelities far
more common
this is mystically backed women tend to
cheat at least within marriages and
relationships due to dissatisfaction
either within the bedroom or emotionally
so we cheat for different reasons but
you do see that women at younger ages
when the option is there and when they
are more viable do cheat more than men
they got more options they're just
better at hiding it so it doesn't seem
like that perception you know got more
options yeah it is what it is so we're
speaking in generalities I don't want
people to convey like actually I cheat
well into my 30s
well me okay there's there's exceptions
I'm talking about the bell curve it
doesn't mean it's a blanket for everyone
here's the thing with her comment she's
not wrong but she's not entirely right
when she says black men cheat a lot you
have to understand that's for reality
because she's around black people you
know I mean it's like people that sable
black people do a lot of crime against
black people white people do a lot of
crimes against white people
Asians against Asians you know I mean so
that's why it's it's a matter of
proximity and so if you've seen fidelity
around you if you're only around black
people you're gonna assume it's some
more black people probably when your
reality if you go to Latino countries
tell them why me
well you listen to bachata they anything
you don't listen to back dramatic ass
music for no reason about infidelity and
I'm gonna epstein myself and this
everything is a laugh it's just a thing
is just like hey so yeah you want to go
out I don't have a boyfriend
yeah infidelity is not exclusive but
within North American context to back
her up it is true that statistically
speaking black men do cheat more than
the other races I think Latinos are like
a really close second I thought that
black men did cheat black boys cheat not
black men set out the solid man the guys
overall I just think that when it comes
to this discussion basically what was
her claim her claim was that we don't
know how to flow we have a problem and
we have to work on it that's what she
said
I think everybody needs to work on their
faithfulness because I'll be honest with
you if you go to Latin American
countries if you go to some parts of
Europe infidelities is ingrained in the
cost more so than here it would be it's
just it's just a thing it's just this is
the thing so you know I think it's a
mixture of things I think the media and
culture biology some other things it's a
mixture of culture biology and a lot of
different things but you know I think
when it comes to these discussions all
we can do is work on ourselves as
individuals try to set a good example
and try to not engage in the behavior
that we think is negative sadly so yeah
pretty much all I got anything else want
to add about infidelity not man that's
pretty much it told you that studios
that's 30 that started on Rajee mixed
you up right didn't know it
biology heck side this biology
[Music]
[Applause]
I be honest with you guys like people
been asking why we haven't done a
podcast before this why why haven't we
why she didn't want to do
I feel like [ __ ] talk too much that
should be the name of the podcast things
talk too much I don't need to hear you
this often I'm like I never want to be
the one of the people that talks too
much like I have another podcast in
French and we do it for 30 minutes yeah
we was not into that two-hour thing
where people just talk about and we have
precise subjects so we we we talk about
it like what surprised about that's
right and we just but we don't want it
yeah we don't want to be there for two
hours talking about two hours is you
know it's fun but it's not everybody
that could do it for two hours it's not
everybody that got the Mojo the stamina
to go off for two hours and be
interesting and you're like oh yeah like
every bits of it you know so I get it
downside to that those like in 30
minutes you just start to really get in
a groove yeah things really pick up well
so it's always finding like that sweet
spot cuz I know what like when we're
hanging out as friends like just
generally speaking and we're having
conversations it takes about an hour
before we get into like the really juicy
juicy stuff yeah yeah yeah yum-yum yeah
yeah yeah because then you're in a flow
and everything is just moving super
smoothly so I know if 30 minutes is the
right amount like two hours but I feel
like that's me the person I know for I
had to come to terms of the fact that
I'm not the general public and you're
definitely not and so what I think is
like yo y'all [ __ ] talk too much for
them is I please talk some more
yeah and I'm saying even that's doing to
YouTube videos a week sometimes I'm like
ah damn we got a it's a lot to stick
with but then people are one every day
one more one more like yo yeah I'm down
and I'm trying to curb my internet usage
and like my online media stuff and so
for me I'm like damn do I want to
contribute to everyone but everyone has
their own needs and desires just because
I want to curb mine
doesn't mean other people want to curb
that no you can't you can't father
everybody know they have to do their own
choices so if they want more let the man
more you know yeah let them eat cake
flipside to that though is like if you
if you know it's relatively unhealthy
then the sex caused by your logic you
know what I'm saying it's like you're
not gonna father them you could also
just deal drugs and but yeah I'm not
their dad it's their responsibility you
know I'm saying it's not the same thing
obviously I went to an extreme example
but it isn't that same spectrum because
there's a life studies not back up it's
not the same thing at all brother
there's a lot of studies to back up the
fact that in moderation social media is
fine but most people use in excess and
it does lead to a lot of private that
yes they care a lot of drugs drugs in
moderation a lot of them are fine in
excess they'd be a little bit of Aaron
near in there it's always good you know
you know hey if you're having surgery
100% hey at Friday myth you know I mean
a little bit of meth Friday bet Friday
some people do meatless Friday one for
the go